point of view or we don't believe in the
Divinity of Christ I think that there
you can make an argument that the the
gospels which were written he was just a
prophet signif no no no we don't even
believe he's a prophet what do you think
he was what do you guys think I mean I
what I what do I think he was
historically I
think do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop all of
us it's extremely beneficial to do this
course definitely recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training now three two one
goam brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
welcome to another video this coward Ben
Shapiro yes he's a coward muhamad was
exposed him many times uh Norman
Frankenstein U has challenged him many
times but he's just cowardly run away
even hijab did and he's a coward yes he
even gulped yes when he saw hijab on
camera yes I don't blame him he's a boy
that's why so brothers and sisters in
this video he clearly clearly insults
Jesus peace be upon him let's watch it
for ourself in the joh John uh Joe Rogan
podcast where he says what he said about
Jesus peace be upon him and this is what
the beliefs sadly of Judaism is point of
view or we don't believe in the Divinity
of Christ I that there you can make an
argument that the the gospels which were
written he was just a prophet in
signific no no no we don't believe he
was a prophet what do you think he was
what do you guys think I mean I what I
what do I think he was historically I
think he was a Jew who tried to lead a
revolt against the Romans and got killed
for his trouble just like a lot of other
Jews at that time who were crucified for
trying to lead revolts against the Roman
and got killed for their trouble so he
became Legend in story and it became a
bigger and bigger deal as time yeah he
had a group of followers and then that
gradually grew and then you think
resurrected no that's not that's not a a
Jewish belief okay just want yeah no
we're not into we're not in the miracle
stories no that's that's you don't have
any miracles not not by Jesus right
there ones in the Old Testament yeah so
guys you saw that for yourself that
apparently Jesus was a troublemaker a
criminal or whatever for that matter the
only person that's a criminal you coward
is you not Prophet mam Prophet Jesus
peace be upon Him Jesus P was an
honorable person Allah subhana Praises
him in the Quran many places he's
mentioned the Quran and we as Muslims
believe in his mother that his mother
was a righteous woman not the way you
guys slander
her adult
she was a righteous woman who gave birth
to the Messiah which you guys reject as
Muslims we accept and you know what's
really funny the Jewish uh the Zionist
Lobby yes in America are composed by a
lot of Christians yes EV Evangelical
Christians who are pushing this agenda
and supporting Israel because they want
Armageddon yes they want their false
Messiah to come whereas us Muslims rever
and love Jesus peace be upon him so much
that we defend his honor and you yet
will go and support people like Ben
Shapiro who insult your you know holy uh
Jesus peace be upon him who you deem to
be God for that matter okay we as
Muslims we believe in Jesus peace be
upon him you Christians reject the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him the
Jews reject Jesus and Muhammad peace be
upon him we as Muslims we affirm Jesus
and Moses peace be upon him and we speak
good of them and no muslim could be a
Muslim who do not believe in Jesus peace
be upon him so Christians wake up we
Muslims are not your enemy okay we all
we do is ask you guys that you do not
say that God is a man Jesus that's the
only thing we say like Allah says in the
Quran tell the people of the book that
we come to Common terms between us and
you that we worship nobody but God just
like Jesus did he said there is only one
true God and that is uh the father okay
he always referred to the father
brothers and sisters and for that matter
for you guys to carry on supporting
individuals like Ben Shapiro who's an
outright Zionist who's an outright
individual who supports the massacre and
the killing of Palestinian children
babies for that matter yes and some of
that their poit politicians are calling
for them to Nuke Gaza for them to kill
innocent men women and children and
spare nobody yes brothers and sisters we
as Muslims are on the H we believe that
Jesus is going to come he is the Messiah
we believe his return is going to come
he's going to break the cross he's going
to tell the Christians he never told
them to worship him he's not God he is
going to come and establish justice and
inshallah the Muslims will be on his
side and he will follow the Sharia of
Islam and will prevail and justice will
prevail he's going to have his term when
he comes he's going to in mat is going
to uham is going to join his army and
they're going to defeat the Antichrist
the Dalal the Dalal that claims that he
is God the one that's going to do
Miracles and guess who believes that God
can a human being who does Miracles uh
and claims to be divine yes the
Christians the Christians believe this
we don't Muslims don't believe this and
that's the reason why we believe the
Jews and the Christians are going to
fall for the Antichrist trap of
pretending that he's a messiah and
inshallah the Muslims are going to
follow the true Messiah Jesus peace be
upon him and be in his army fighting
those
evildoers that's all I have to say
inshah Ben Shapiro you are the real
criminal you are the Troublemaker not
Jesus peace be upon Him shame on you and
shame on every Christian who supports
you the hatred in your heart is so great
so big that you will go and support
somebody who insults your religion and
your God till next
time there is nothing worthy of worship
except Allah subhana tala and we call
our Christian and Jewish Brothers to the
one true faith of worshiping the god the
way he deserves to be
worshiped